20 عاما تمر على الحرب الامريكيه في
العراق والاثار الصحيه على سكان محافظه
صلاح الدين ما تزال باقيه نتحدث عن قاعده
بلد اكبر قاعده جويه في العراق والتي تبعد
64 كيلومترا الى الشمال من العاصمه بغداد
خلال ذروه العمليات عام 2011 استضافت
القاعده 36 الفا من الافراد العسكريين
والمتعاقدين المدنيين فيها للتخلص من
مخلفات القاعده العسكريه والتي كانت معضله
وجد لها حل قائم على حرقها في حفر حرق على
مدار الساعه حفره الحرق في قاعده بلد كانت
الاكبر في العراق امتدت على مساحه تقترب
من عشره ابنه تم فيها حرق ما يقرب من 150
طنا من النفايات يوميا واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه قدمت متكرره للبنتاجون حول
معلومات المواد التي تم حرقها الا ان
الوزاره قالت انها لا تحتفظ بسجلات واضحه
حول المواد المحروقه الاثار الصحيه ظهرت
على الجنود بالفعل في قاعده بلد وايضا على
السكان المحليين دراسه امريكيه وجدت ان
سبعه في المئه من الجنود العائدين من بلد
عانوا من امراض الجهاز التنفسي المعاناه
طالت ايضا اهالي بلد الذين ارتفعت بينهم
نسب الاصابه بالربو وانواع مختلفه اخرى من
السرطان دون ان يوجد لدى الكثير منهم
تاريخ مرضي سابق او عوامل مساعده على جانب
الاخر وبين وبعد عقدين من الزمن وقع رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن العام الماضي تشريعا
يقر بالفعل بوجود صله محتمله بين حفر
الحرق والامراض التي تعرض لها الجنود ليتم
شمول اكثر من 200 الف جندي ومت عاقد مدني
امريكي بفوائد الرعايه الصحيه